bonjour mesdames messieurs ici céline
galipeau bienvenue à cette émission
spéciale sur le 75e anniversaire du
débarquement de normandie
au matin du 6 juin 1944 en plein coeur
de la seconde guerre mondiale cette
gigantesque opération militaire va
permettre aux forces alliées les
américains les britanniques les
canadiens les foules soldats de la
france libre de revenir sur le sol
français et d'ouvrir ainsi la voie à la
libération d'une grande partie de
l'europe et à la victoire finale sur
l'allemagne nazie
alors vous voyez ces images qui nous
parviennent en direct de courseulles sur
mer c'est juno beach donc cette plage où
les canadiens ont débarqué les premiers
ministres justin trudeau à edouard
philippe de la france vont présider la
cérémonie qui doit débuter dans une demi
heure en hommage aux soldats canadiens
qui ont participé à ce jour j alors vous
voyez la plage plusieurs vétérans ont
fait le voyage et ils sont déjà ils
commencent à se rassembler pour
l'occasion il fait assez beau en fait il
fait soleil autour de 15 degrés est pour
nous rappeler ce qu'a été ce
débarquement de normandie sont
importants je vous présente tout de
suite nos deux invités
marie-eve vaillancourt halle et
historienne et elle est responsable
justement des expositions au centre
d'une oblige donc c'est ce musée
canadien qui se trouve sur la plage donc
vous ce doudou ce fait cette cérémonie
bonjour bienvenue ici à cette émission
si tôt le matin monsieur paradis que
vous connaissez bien que vous avez vu
beaucoup sur nos ondes justement colonel
retraité des forces canadiennes bonjour
alors madame vaillancourt je vais
commencer avec vous sur l'importance la
signification de cette de cette
cérémonie
déjà une image les gens se rassemblent
autant de présence militaire civil il ya
beaucoup de jeunes des gens sur le site
logement
la signification ce qui est un moment de
reconnaissance importants qui se passe
au jour
alors on semble avoir des petits
problèmes de micro alors on va passer à
monsieur paradis sûr on va pendant qu'on
va régler ça
l'importance donc de cette bataille dans
cette seconde guerre mondiale c'est
quand même un tournant important
oui on la demi-heure 1944 la cinquième
année de la guerre les premières années
ont été très défavorable
les indics où la vigne aux soviétiques
maintenant après quatre années et demie
de guerre
le moment était venu d'avoir reconstruit
des forces alliées libre aux
britanniques
le moment était venu de d'ouvrir un
second front majeur pour donner le coup
de grâce à l'allemagne
non non c'est quand même quelque chose
qui a beaucoup marqué l'imaginaire ce
grand débarquement cette gigantesque
opération
on va se rendre tout de suite sur
consoles sur mer rejoindre jean françois
bélanger sur les lieux donc de cette
cérémonie qui doit commencer je disais
vers midi heure locale dans une
vingtaine de minutes alors jean-françois
il ya on voit des jeunes ya beaucoup de
monde qui est arrivé quelle quelle est
l'ambiance
oui plusieurs centaines de personnes qui
sont arrivées déjà beaucoup sont arrivés
dès l'aube de l'ouverture en fait des
des portes ici au centre juno beach où
il ya un musée d'ailleurs canadien qui
est installé comme permis ces gens là
beaucoup de jeunes vous savez c'est
vraiment ils sont au centre de toutes
les cérémonies ces jeunes là parce qu'on
veut vraiment les impliqués là-dedans
s'assurer que personne n'oublie le
sacrifice des soldats dont il ya 1500
jeunes canadiens qui sont venus ici qui
vient d'un peu partout à travers le pays
y a des une centaine de jeunes français
qui sont là aussi beaucoup de normes à
la population locale qui est présente
aussi en grand nombre vous savez les
normands sont très reconnaissants aux
soldats canadiens pour eux ils sont très
conscients du sacrifice qui a été faite
savent très bien que c'est grâce à eux
que ils doivent leur liberté d'ailleurs
il suffit de se promener ici en
normandie
chaque année autour du mois de juin on
voit beaucoup de drapeaux canadiens peu
partout tous les gens qui mettent des
drapeaux canadiens sur leurs maisons des
drapeaux québécois aussi par exemple à
bernières sur mer les la population
locale est très attaché au fait que
c'est un régiment qui
la chaudière qui est venu libérer donc
donc la région et ça ça a permis des
contacts plus facile à l'époque
évidemment avec cet accent quitté dix
ans les mots étaient différents mais les
gens je comprenais est salée les
normands ne l'ont pas oubliée donc
beaucoup de monde ici on a parlé à
certains d'entre eux tout à l'heure
beaucoup de québécois aussi qui étaient
là qui ont organisé un peu leurs
vacances pour s'assurer de pouvoir être
ici sur place pour cet événement
historique jeux proposés les écouter
c'est l'heure juste d'imaginer ça c'est
vraiment le rein
ces gens là ont dû vivre des moments
avant de mourir
la plupart ont dû vivre des moments
épouvantable et il faut qu'il faut plus
haut on a un marché si la plage
concernant six lots qui ont débarqué que
c'est là qu'ils y ont essayé ça vraiment
beaucoup marqué on a fait une minute de
silence pour se rappeler des sols puis
c'était quelque chose mais ça
m'impressionne beaucoup
surtout le dynamisme qu'ils expriment
prend pour être venu ici il n'y a pas de
regrets sont venus ici pour défendre la
patrie puisse hansen j'appréciais
beaucoup oui oui on sent l'émotion est
justement toute la semaine vous avez
rencontré des anciens combattants
quelles sont leurs attentes de cette
cérémonie
céline c'est toujours frappant de voir
la santé à quel point ils sont
dynamiques ces hommes-là qui pour la
plupart de ces hommes et ces femmes
parce qu'il ya aussi quelques femmes par
milieu voir à quel point ils sont ils
sont pleins d'énergie alors que beaucoup
d'entre eux ont pris près de cinq ans
c'est le cas de 100 ans c'est le cas par
exemple de monsieur alphonse vautours de
cap-pelé au nouveau-brunswick à qui on a
parlé qui va voir va fêter ses 100 ans
imaginez au mois d'octobre prochain le
parisien me suis dit val qui lui était
dans la manche entre de protéger les
gens qui débarquait ses frères d'armes
qui débarqué sur les plages et parmi
ceux qui ont des parcs et sur les plages
évidemment il ya monsieur jean trempe
que vous avez rencontré d'ailleurs à
montréal qui était très très ému on ya
parlé encore hier au cimetière canadien
de béni sur mer il est très très attaché
à ses frères d'armes et céline il ne
s'explique pas comment ça se fait que
lui est encore là c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui l'émeut pas chaque fois chaque
fois qu'il se rend dans un cimetière
militaire et puis ça fait plusieurs fois
qui revient ici en france
il est toujours extrêmement ému je
propose l'écouté ont rencontré hier à
l'issue de la cérémonie au cimetière de
béni sur mer je préfère que jose
chantante et allaient bénéficier ici
mais pour poser une question pourquoi
2 il est non moins j'ai cru
c'est les pompiers
c'est la vie c'est comme enjeu mondial
est un peu pareil j'ai fait
et puis de muzols de l'est que mes
compagnons qui sont entassés cei palois
de 15 jours
oui vous avez raison c'est vraiment
impressionnant de voir ses anciens
combattants à l'orage avec toute cette
énergie avec toute cette émotion pour
les français aussi vous le disais ainsi
commémoration elles font partie de leur
devoir de mémoire
puis c'est une mission qu'il prenne très
à coeur seul il faut voir chaque fois
que les anciens combattants ici se
déplacent partout en normandie ils sont
applaudis sur leur passage par la
population locale qui n'a pas oublié le
sacrifice qui est très consciente de ce
qu'elle doit à donc ces combattants
alliés qui était très très jeune ans il
avait 19 ans va être certains se sont
enrôlés ils ont menti sur leur âge et se
sont envolés à 16 ans pour venir ici et
donc les français sont très très
reconnaissant et les français aussi
savent le la fragilité de la terre c'est
le cas surtout des normands et c'est
pour ça que ils sont très attachés donc
à 7 ce relais qui doit se faire avec les
nouvelles générations s'assurer que
personne n'oublie on a parlé tout à
l'heure
donc sophie gaugain vice-présidente de
la région normandie qui nous explique
l'importance ici en normandie donc du
devoir de mémoire pour les normands
c'est une gratitude éternelle
il n'y a pas une famille de normandie
qui n'est pas été concernée de façon
différente par le débarquement et
ensuite cette histoire qui nous a
définitivement marqué dans nos villes
dans nos chères dans nos familles et
donc l'attachement est réel et nous
avons vraiment ce sens du devoir
vis-à-vis et des vétérans et aujourd'hui
des canadiens qui sont réunis à
courseulles ensemble dans cette unité
cette fraternité
ouais c'est vraiment bien dit et
jean-françois décrivez-nous un peu donc
cette cérémonie qu'on va voir dans une
vingtaine de minutes cérémonie donc
présidé par le premier canadien justin
trudeau qui vient tout juste d'atterrir
d'arriver à deauville il s'en vient ici
par la suite il va être rejoint ici par
edouard philippe le premier ministre
français qui doit aussi prendre la
parole au cours de la cérémonie justin
trudeau va parler autour de 6 heures 30
heure de l'est au canada et puis par la
suite il y aura aussi edouard philippe
une cérémonie qui va être marquée
évidemment par tous les les
traditionnels de ce genre de cérémonie
la clé minute de silence avec le respect
qui est l'hommage qui est rendu aux
disparus
et puis le moment peut-être pu être plus
spécial c'est lorsque les anciens
combattants qui sont présents ici vont
se diriger sur la plage la plage de
courseulles sur mer où certains d'entre
eux ont débarqué donc ou à l'aube du 6
juin 1944 ils vont déposer des gerbes
sur place ça sans doute le clou de cette
cérémonie
jean-françois vous allez suivre tout ça
pour nous et on vous retrouvera tout au
long l'émission merci beaucoup à plus
tard
là bas alors on revient donc sur ce
débarquement
si on l'a de voir cette cérémonie ça
risque d'être très touchant c'est l'une
on disait des grandes opérations
militaires
avec évidemment des chiffres qui sont
impressionnants on peut l'y voir
peut-être ça va nous donner une idée de
l'ensemble donc 133 1000 soldats 22000
parachutistes 12000 avions 6500 navires
et regarder pour les canadiens 14 mille
soldats 4 150 parachutistes 880 avions
sang neuf navires
ces paradis donc c'est le plus grand
débarquement de l'histoire en fait et ça
marque vraiment un tournant dans la
dernière oui effectivement alors ce jour
j étais un point culminant de la
deuxième guerre mondiale et la deuxième
guerre mondiale est un événement
marquant dans l'histoire du 20e siècle
alors ce jour j était crucial il fallait
le réussir à tout prix alors les moyens
ont été déployés pour réussir cette
victoire et puis repoussé les allemands
vers l'allemagne en conjonction avec
l'avancée de l'armée rouge sur le front
est sur le front russe
alors tout était mis en place durant les
années précédant de 1941 à 1944 avec
l'entraînement de soldats
l'approvisionnement l'arrivée de
matériel majeur des etats-unis du canada
et c'est vraiment l'impression d'avoir
tous ces bateaux qui arrivait sur la
plage où il s'agit intrus demande une
coordination extraordinaire et on se
rappelle n'y avait pas d'ordinateur à
l'époque leur fille devait être planifié
lors des conférences et puis tout le
secret devait être conservé également
alors c'est une opération extrêmement
complexe avec les moyens qui ont été
utilisés avec également les la menace le
risque d'une telle opération ne se
rappelle que l'opération à dieppe avec
un casier chèque même un échec
alors il a fallu il avait fallu
apprendre avec les débarquements
l'afrique du nord et ensuite en sicile
en italie a tiré les leçons
ce qui paie avec l'équipement nécessaire
entraîner les soldats des centaines de
milliers de soldats
gagner la bataille de l'atlantique gagné
la bataille aérienne renforcer la
résistance française pour nuire aux
allemands alors tout ça demande une
coordination d'une complexité
extraordinaire
donc c'est pour ça en fait que ça prend
du temps un malin vaillancourt parce que
on est quand même dans la cinquième
année de la guerre on peut se demander
pourquoi ça a pris autant de temps pour
que les forces alliées interviennent
nous il fallait absolument réunir toutes
sortes de conditions vous en avez une
main plusieurs ça a débuté avec une
supériorité aérienne et navale de tout
l'espace autour de la normandie est une
bonne distinction à faire dans de
supériorité et supprime ainsi donc ces
étapes là qui sont toutes liées les unes
avec les autres qui font en sorte qu'ils
ont emmenés vers 44 on arrive à
maîtriser toutes les eaux de la manche
des mines et d'ailleurs les eaux de la
manche pour pouvoir créer un passage
pour les trois alliés dans les péniches
de débarquement l'écran les grands
bâtiments naveau est aussi avoir une
suprématie aérienne
ces facteurs le sont très importants
sinon il ya des risques ça échoue si on
n'a pas la commande absolu d r et d au
préalable du débarquement dans tout ça
fait en sorte qu'en 44 oui effectivement
on est prêt mais pas avant alors on va
regarder tout de suite une carte un peu
de l'europe pour voir à l'occupation des
forces aux allemands quand même qui
occupe une bonne partie de l'europe
alors on le voit là en journée
évidemment si l'occupation allemande
oui alors s'ils ont pu regarder la carte
à droite il ya le front est
entre les forces de l'armée rouge
l'armée rouge a réussi à repousser en
1944 entre 1942 et 1944 russe et
repousser l'armée allemande d'environ
1000 km alors l'armée rouge et
maintenant
de la pologne et a donc apporté de notre
offensive vers les frontières de
l'allemagne
quelques moues simplement sur le front
sud dès lors les alliés ont débarqué en
afrique du nord ont battu l'afrika korps
du général rommel et ont débarqué
ensuite en italie remonte péniblement la
péninsule italienne inverse à rome
on attend vraiment ce front ouest à
l'ouverture de ce front ouest qui se
fera donc en normandie
oui qui avait été initialement anticipée
pour 1943 sous l'impulsion du président
roosevelt qui voulait accélérer les
choses
mais bon tout il a réussi à influencer
le président américain pour 10 rebonds
attaquons le le ventre mou de
l'occupation allemande ou dans le jeu
d'aller en italie
et puis bon mais il fallait quand même
conservé garder à l'oeil l'avancée de
l'armée rouge
et puis churchill craignait beaucoup de
l'armée rouge déferlent à travers toute
l'europe occidentale alors il fallait
faire ce débarquement pour gagner le
territoire de gagner le maximum de
territoires avant l'armée rouge
également
alors madame est en cours pourquoi le
choix de la normandie 6 pas le choix le
plus évident on va regarder encore une
fois une autre carte parce que on aurait
pu penser que ça se ferait dans le pas
de calais donc un peu plus au nord un
peu plus proche des des côtes de
l'angleterre
et finalement c'est ce sont ce sont les
plages de normandie pourquoi il s'agit
de déjouer l'ennemi
dans semer le doute le plus longtemps
possible et de mettre les positions
allemandes un peu en porte-à-faux
c'est-à-dire impossibilité de d'affirmer
avec certitude où sera ce fameux lieu du
débarquement
ce qui fait que c'est vrai que
évidemment la normandie c'est pas les
eaux l'endroit idéal
on n'a pas de porc d'eau profonde ce
sont évidemment des aspects qui sont des
incontournables pour la réussite du
débarquement avoir accès à des ports
pour le ravitaillement la logistique
c'est incontournable
la normandie n'a pas ça donc il ya une
opération qui fait en sorte que on cache
à l'ennemi le plus longtemps possible et
c'est ce doute qui va perdurer même
jusqu'aux premières heures du
débarquement qui fait en sorte qu'il n'y
a pas une quantité phénoménale
d'allemands qui est déployée uniquement
sur la normandie etc ces précieuses
heures au début du débarquement où on va
avoir une très forte présente à
l'incompétence allemande qui va nous
permettre de consolider certaines
certaine nos objectifs est de préparer
la contre attaque est donc l effet de
surprise qui joue beaucoup dans ce
débarquement donc le débarquement il
prévu le 5 juin en fait tout a été
minutieusement préparé ça devait être le
5 juin mais les conditions météo sont
tellement mauvaise qu'on est obligé de
retard du sort au lendemain et donc au
lendemain du
le 6 juin à l'aube donc voilà le
débarquement qui se fait à peu près
simultanément évidemment on voit l' isr
sont un peu différente à cause de la
tempête sur l'atlantique
mais les américains donc débarque sur la
plage d'utah donc dommage les
britanniques sur la plage sur le secteur
gold les canadiens sur cette fameuse
plage juno
oui en fait les services météo à lyon
est il supérieur au service météo
allemand les services météo allemand
vous ne voyez que la manche les
conditions météorologiques au dessus de
la manche serait absolument accès grable
et puis qu'est un débarquement était
impossible alors beaucoup de commandants
allemands ont profité de cette situation
météorologique pour prendre un petit con
généraux mais les parties à fêter
l'anniversaire de son épouse en
allemagne d'autres bons sont allés se
divertir un peu à paris alors les
allemands étaient pris par surprise ne
croyait pas qu'un débarquement serait
possible et le nord de son côté a
organisé dans la nuit du 4 au 5 et cinq
ou six prévoyaient initialement oui un
département le sens que les conditions
d'être trop mauvaise pour prendre la mer
alors même si services météo ont dit
hier une petite accalmie ce sera pas le
bouton idéal mais il ya une fenêtre qui
s'ouvre alors un sonar dit allons-y
et puis c'est notre seule occasion sinon
il faudra retarder l'opération d'environ
un mois
je vais donc le grand le grand manitou
l'acquis qui supervisait cette grande
opération
il supervisait toutes les forces alliées
oui alors ça fait soixante quinze ans
sur les quatorze mille canadiens qui ont
participé à ce département il ne reste
plus de 500 qui sont encore avec nous
plusieurs vous l'avez vu son présent
d'ailleurs à courseulles sur mer
d'autres vont y être par lien vidéo et
parmi eux pierre gauthier est un vétéran
du régiment de la chaudière le seul
régiment francophone qui a participé à
cette opération faisait partie la
deuxième vague du débarquement le 6 juin
je les rencontrer chez lui à chambly il
y a quelques jours on va écouter cette
entrevue
je goûte et merci de nous accorder cette
entrevue jeudi
ça va faire 75 ans depuis le
débarquement de normandie
qu'est ce que ça représente pour vous
aujourd'hui cet anniversaire est ce que
ça reste important pour vous c'est fait
une chose spéciale pour bois puis les
canadiens de ma génération
ça fait soixante quinze ans mais c'est
encore frais d'amendements dans ma
mémoire je fais encore des mémos var et
venez cauchemar moi vous êtes resté
marqué par c'est rare et c'est avec moi
toute ma vie et quels souvenirs vous
avez de ce débarquement et jouit dans
vos bateaux en angleterre puis arrivent
les bords de la manche on a laissé les
gros bateaux qu'on embarque dans les
petits bateaux la plage on est exposé
d'atterrir la journée avant la hausse à
poser ou journée puis une nuit sur
nouveaux bateaux attendent parce que là
la température est importe la manière
des vagues y avait une tempête et 20 ans
pas être comme soyons c'était aux idées
léo débarque à main comme son dieu on
était celui bâtonnat d'un fournisseur
le majorité on a va mal de mer les seuls
soldes autre milieu qui ne va pas le mal
de mal cette année gaspésien fait gagner
à nous et ils s'étaient habitués ils
étaient habitués vie d'un des bateaux je
vous pour nous c'était des conditions
difficiles et cordes soyeuses
il n'y avait pas de place pour pour
secourir se reposer on était en état
dans les cales des bateaux
c'est un seul manque une grosse boîte à
raul et va pas de lier pour s'asseoir
dormi on ne consulte trentaine d'heures
dans ces bateaux attendent
puis là un moment donné vous êtes sortie
des bateaux vous êtes descendus des
bateaux dans l'eau on a descendu et au
midi ils ont mis des gros des filets et
fit les gros câble
pendant les échanges de sifflet pour
avoir manqué des petits bateaux ça
dangereux et parce que les petits
bateaux hamon table ça désolé les gars
en décembre c'est ça il faut pas oublier
qu'on a qu à l'infini surtout avec notre
carabine et c est donc là les petits
bateaux vous amène vers la plage c'est
ça c'est et nuit encore comme ça les
petits bateaux se sont manoeuvrés en
ligne ou stopper le soleil est levé
bilan de la journée était les villes les
petits bateaux en france et vers la
plage monument moi on était sur seille
de ce petit bateau puis des allemands
bombardier et puis à deux de ces battles
ont été détruits à la mer
sont jamais rendus à la plage et puis on
leur donne on fait 100 pieds de large
on interdit sur une classe g 20 pour 400
fidèles
le mari d'abord on est une cible plus
aux tagueurs nomade vous arrivez sur la
plage c'est des conditions difficiles il
faut marcher longtemps dans l'eau avec
votre équipement sûr qu'il ya des avions
us commencent à ckoi il y avait du bruit
avait payé le bruit était énormément de
but
une centaine de bateaux qui étaient sous
l'eau encore bombardé proche de la plage
parce que nous allons être à cacher dans
des endroits pour se défendre
ces bateaux leurs bobards des ces
endroits lost proche de la plage pour
empêcher les allemands des ventes mais
ça devait être terrible pour vous
lorsque en main comme expérience peu
important surtout débarqué de la plage
c'est ce qui est la chose la plus
difficile à faire plus peur vous en avez
tué dernièrement j'ai fait j'ai fait ma
job j'ai fait ma job césure et tiré sur
les jeunes hommes de quais saison
qu'est-ce qui a été le plus dur dans
cette aventure là pour vous voir vos
amis mes confrères blessé tu ta lui les
soldes aucun avis les soldats comme moi
qui ont servi sous cobo il est rattaché
à la hauteur du boul
c'est quand je suis venu au canada
pendant la guerre le bata avec le monde
1 quelqu'ait m'opposait - l'abus d'un
point sa gueule puis sa part pas de
talent et de l'obsession du dic sûrs du
tout
mettez-vous n'est plus la chose locale à
des sites où j'utilise là j'avais 19 ans
et puis j'ai tu veux tu fais les jeunes
aux normales saurait quand je veux nous
rien nada mas prague et jallet des
travers de la montréal puis je me bats
ta ble ment avec liv clic amalgame de
roulement l'appui d'un poisson cru
battre
ben non même dans mon ouvrage est
combattue et déjà aujourd'hui ils ont
mis un nom là dessus un pur je m'en
excuse pour après la guerre
compétitivité personnes ça existait même
pas vous êtes parvenu tout celle de
cette guerre là chez soi on était vous
être vous avez trouvé votre épouse là
bas mon époux faire du salvador on a
dansé ensemble on s'est trouvés culte à
malines si vous êtes tombé amoureux tout
c'est pas mal oui pas mal oui elle était
avec trois ou quatre de ses femmes parmi
les cas c'est celle que je souhaitais ça
fesse ou salés 14 ans au mois de juillet
qui est avec la même femme bas 900 et 14
heures
[Musique]
à quoi vous allez penser le 6 juin
quand on quand ça arrive cette journée
là comment vous vous sentez journée
tranquille pour - je suis allé en france
où trois ou quatre fois prend la guerre
pour billy si les bolides du nord puis
jours pour sa plage
j'ai vu d'être marcher sur la plage
tout ça est l'endroit des millavois pour
n'a pas normal
j'ai vu tellement tanger où ses plages
c'est mieux de l'évier faut pas oublier
que les grosses blessures les grosses
mortalité sont arrivés sur la plage j'ai
opéré une fois me depuis la guerre ah
ben
jones avocat sexuelle une guerre mais
nous en tout cas on vous dit merci pour
ce que vous avez fait merci beaucoup
monsieur gautier de cette entrevue
alors oui voilà cette plage où monsieur
gautier ne veut plus aller parce que
c'est douloureux on sent tellement le
souvenir est tellement vif encore chez
ses anciens combattants c'est comme si
c'était hier souviennent des petits
détails et tout ça et c'est le
débarquement c'est le moment où ils
débarquent sur la plage qui semblait
avoir marqué davantage peut-être que les
combats ont peut-être qu'ils ont occulté
les combats par la suite mais c'est ça
qui reste un os de la ligne de fracture
entre tout l'entraînement depuis des
années maintenant c'est la réalité c'est
le début de la fin de la guerre s'ils
survivent pour s'égarer puis la
traversée était absolument misérable il
y avait le mal de mer les uns des états
transit à fatiguer affaibli par le mal
de mer et maintenant ils doivent
débarquer là si la confusion ce bonbon
le meilleur plan possible tombe à l'eau
lorsqu'on franchit la ligne de départ et
puis là qu'est ce qui compte c'est la
cohésion entre les petits groupes de
soldats retrouvés sont en sélection
d'une dizaine de soldats sont peloton
d'une trentaine de soldats sa compagnie
et puis identifiées l'objectif est avec
les camarades qui ne sont pas tombées se
lancer à travers la mitraille à travers
le bruit la fumée et puis richir
atteindre l'objectif quitter cette
foutue plage où là on est vraiment
vraiment vulnérable alors six ans qu'on
voit des images de cette cérémonie donc
ils se préparent vous voyez les anciens
combattants qui sont rassemblés sur
cette plage et
c'est quand même important de comprendre
à quel point c'est difficile pour ceux
qui arrivaient les canadiens qui
arrivait sur la plage alors que les
allemands étaient quand même postés un
peu partout et installe is plus
difficile pour des soldats qui arrive
comme ça
évidemment la plupart des positions
allemandes n'avaient pas été détruite au
préalable faut savoir que les
bombardements était pas d'une efficacité
incroyable
donc la plupart des positions étaient à
neutraliser étaient intacts et il
fallait exactement comme vous avez
décrit s'organiser dans des petits au
niveau du peloton de la section pour
surmonter ses premiers obstacles à les
neutraliser surtout ne pas perdre ce qui
avait été acquis parce que falloir que
la marée monte
oui donc il ya pas beaucoup de temps
avant qu'on soit confronté à la seconde
ligne de défense des allemands derrière
les villages dans les terres alors la
cérémonie doit commencer dans moins
d'une minute on va retourner rapidement
revoir jean françois bélanger donc
jean-françois ça se prépare ça va
commencer bientôt un tout à fait on a vu
céline déjà des jeunes arrivés de la
plage avec des bottes 359 paire de
bottes qui symbolise autant de soldats
canadiens morts lors de cette première
journée le 6 juin 1944 d'employés
journée assez meurtrière avec cette
résistance des forces allemandes
on va voir au cours des cérémonies donc
là il ya prés ministre trudeau qui est
arrivé sur place qui s'entretient
actuellement avec son homologue français
edouard philippe la cérémonie doit
commencer d'ici quelques minutes
elle va être ça va commencer par 21
coups de canon puis les hymnes nationaux
on va entendre un peu plus tard ont des
avions qui vont nous passer au dessus de
la tête des avions d'époque y aura bien
évidemment les allocutions qui vont être
prononcée par justin trudeau et par
edouard philippe
chacune doit durer environ une vingtaine
de minutes et 2 on s'attend ce qui parle
donc du devoir de mémoire c'est vraiment
un thème récurrent ici pour ces
célébrations ya une partie aussi
j'allais dire
artistique donc on va entendre par
exemple les et nice systems qui vont
chanter et puis luc de larochellière et
puis la composante autochtone est aussi
très importante
on l'a vu lors de la cérémonie au
cimetière de béni sur mer hier c'est
important en fait depuis pour ça semble
important aux yeux de justin trudeau qui
veut chaque fois rappelé donc cet
élément important de l'histoire
canadienne rappeler aussi qu'il y avait
des autochtones parmi donc les soldats
qui sont combattus pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale
donc beaucoup de monde ici aujourd'hui
évidemment rassemblés à courseulles sur
mer
on est tout l ouest du secteur canadien
de djokovic à vous savez ça s'étend sur
plusieurs villages à courseulles sur mer
et ensuite bernières sur mer où est
débarqué le régiment de la chaudière et
puis un petit peu plus à l'est il ya
saint-aubin-sur-mer donc 8 km de plage
donc où ils ont débarqué les soldats
canadiens le 6 juin 1944 pour rappeler
que c'est eux qui ont fait le plus de
progrès sont ceux qui sont allés le plus
loin dans les terres 10 km dans les
terres
et ça les normands leur sont
reconnaissants et savent que les
canadiens avec coeur au ventre car ils
sont d'accord et ici en juin 1944
très bien merci beaucoup jean-françois
alors on voyait des images donc les
anciens combattants les héros de cette
cérémonie la vue monsieur justement jean
30 donc sept anciens combattants à qui
vous avez parlé jean-françois à qui j'ai
aussi parlé très attachant donc on va
regarder ensemble cette cérémonie qui
doit durer une heure et demi à peu près
et je vous retrouve tout de suite après
avec nos invités
[Musique]
[Musique]
e
mon
[Musique]
on
toujours
[Musique]
m
non
on
oh
le convoi
pourquoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une cérémonie qui devait commencer
un tout petit peu plus tôt mais qui
semble un peu en retard sur l'horaire
que nous avons ici on peut peut-être
parler justement du rôle des canadiens
pendant ce débarquement parce que
jean-françois le mentionnait c'est quand
même des canadiens ont fait les avancées
importantes
ils ont joué un rôle important des
canadiens dans ce débarquement on oublie
peut-être un peu mais il était là et est
bien actif
oui donc en parler
quatorze mille cas matin
j'en ai marqué
mais la bataille de normandie ça va
mobiliser 80
partout sur dix semaines de coma c'est
une énorme campagne avec des pertes qui
vont aller en augmentant
bandit minots en augmentant à travers
les jaunes qui vont vivre les chiffres
sont peut-être moins impressionnant mais
quand même par rapport à la population
canadienne par rapport aux ressources du
canada à l'époque c'est quand même un
très important on va peut-être même un
peu disproportionné par rapport aux
autres prisons mais il faut rappeler
surtout que à cette époque-là en 44 il
ya pas de conscription encore pour le
service outre mer monte
c'est ce qui distingue les canadiennes
des américaines et du sein des
volontaires se sont des volontaires il
n'y a pas de conscription dans tous les
canadiens qui ont débarqué
me c'est juin et qui ont servi durant la
bataille
en italie jusqu'à finalement en mars 45
mois on aura les premiers camps secrets
canadiens à la toute fin de la gare
c'est une contribution volontaire
absolument phénoménale et je pense que
c'est ça que les français saluent le
plus c'est une petite distinction et on
la met pas en avance souvent mais c'est
vrai que ça fait une grosse différence
cette volonté de d'être d'aller servir
votre honneur je pense que comme pour le
but il fait remarquer
on est obligé de tuer des gens mais il
est là de manière volontaire à la base
et c'est ensuite que ces jeunes hommes
un seringue ondes de ckoi la guerre
c'est ce à quoi ils vont devoir faire
face ces dures réalités et on a tendance
peut-être ici au québec a oublié on l'a
on parle beaucoup de la conscription et
donc de l'opposition de 18 canadiens
français de l'époque à la conscription
meoli francophones ont joué un rôle
important aussi dans ce débarquement et
beaucoup de volontaires francophones
beaucoup de volontaires oui le régiment
de la chaudière régiment d'infanterie
composé de francophones comme on dit par
des francophones en français qui a
débarqué dans le premier jour
d'autres régiments francophones
également suivront
c'était une condition à peu près
sinéquanone pour pour que les canadiens
français puissent se sentir impliqués
dans ce conflit qui soit qu'il fasse
parti d'unité francophones ils soient
commandés par des francophones et non
pas par des anglophones alors plusieurs
régiments canadiens français ont été cif
ont été ainsi formés et puis on se sont
entraînés en français et puis dont il y
avait une cohésion qui c'est qui s'est
installée dans ces régimes a canettes
rechute donc important on voit beaucoup
de gens qui sont rassemblés pour cette
cérémonie aujourd'hui qui ce qui se
déroule sur la plage juno et la
cérémonie internationale pour la
première fois un peu plus tard
aujourd'hui va aussi se tenir là donc
sur la plage sur le secteur canadien de
la plage sauce c'est une première pour
la cérémonie internationale
même s'il y aura pas tous les chefs
d'état tous et toutes la pompe peut-être
à laquelle on est habitués pour les à la
grande cérémonie m
ce qu'on a une importance une
reconnaissance du rôle des canadiens -
absolument 75 ans de cérémonie c'est la
première fois on a eu des gros
anniversaire au 50e 60e et là enfin
c'est notre tour vraiment canadien
voulait faire sa place parmi les grands
les américains des britanniques voulu
que une formation canadienne une
division canadienne qui fasse partie de
ce débarquement l'opinion publique
canadien était anxieuse que les
canadiens voient de l'action alors il y
avait des canadiens qui combattait déjà
en italie
les canadiens avaient participé
massivement au 22 juillet puis
maintenant en 44 canadien il fallait on
faisait des pressions pour que l'armée
canadienne soit en première ligne alors
là on nous dit que les premiers
ministres français et canadiens sont
finalement arrivés sur les lieux
donc la cérémonie devrait commencer sous
peu pendant qu'on voit des images
historiques ça c'est les fameuses images
que les soldats canadiens voient en
arrivant et andy barr temps là
dernière sur mer c'est ça la fameuse
maison qu'on voit sur dix huit dernières
sur leur wii alors c'était un des
premiers objectifs des troupes d'assaut
capturer cette maison et ensuite
poursuivre dans les rues des villages
alors voilà juno beach la fameuse plage
et cette cérémonie dont je le disais se
déroulait au centre juno ou vous
travaillez d'ailleurs vous êtes
responsable des expositions et donc de
la transmission enfin du devoir de
mémoire en vain petit peu et du travail
de mémoire aurait donc ce sont les
anciens combattants eux mêmes qui sont à
l'origine de ceux de ce musée canadien
oui le centre juno beach existe depuis
2003 et c'est des vétérans canadiens
jour j qui l'ont créé et qui ont démarré
cette entreprise de levée de fonds
pendant au moins dix ans avant que leur
rêve se réalise donc il était concernée
par la transmission de la mémoire vers
la jeunesse d'abord et avant tout était
jusque là il n'y avait pas de lieu où
ils pouvaient se retrouver donc les
soldats canadiens les anciens
combattants quand il retournait sous
voilà exactement sur les plages
britannique on avait déjà des musées des
lieux de mémoire même chose pour les
américains et pour les canadiens
rien jusqu'en 2003 par bon évidemment
des claques des stèles et des marqueurs
mais pas de lieu où on peut vraiment
expliquer démontrer et transmettre
surtout alors les premiers ministres
devraient arriver sur la scène dans
quelques minutes on va écouter donc
c'est 21 coups de canon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs veuillez vous
lever pour accueillir nos distingués
invités le très honorable justin trudeau
premier ministre du canada monsieur
edouard philippe x men et soeurs
monsieur edouard philippe premier
ministre de la république française
[Applaudissements]
à temps
à
salo nord
[Musique]
1 1
on
[Musique]
m
on
enfin
non
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
l'eau
moment
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
pour l'année civile rowling et à la john
que vous voyez arriver et le cp 140
aurora un aéronefs de patrouille à long
rayon d'action
[Musique]
nice il en parle-t-on français
les sanglots longs des violons de
lanthane nommé m les sanglots longs des
violons de l'automne
les leaders d'une langueur monotone
[Musique]
mais
e
[Musique]
ici londres
les français parlent aux français
veuillez écouter tout d'abord quelques
messages personnels les sanglots longs
des violons de l'automne
j'ai répète les sanglots longs des
violons de l'automne blesse mon coeur
d'une langueur monotone
je répète blesse mon coeur d'une
langueur monotone des world
j'avais 17 ans pierre gauthier seul de
régiment de la chaudière
on va te mettre dans l'infanterie comme
on dit j'avais pas ce que c'était les
fonderies - je connaissais pas ça
l'artillerie l'infanterie tout ça je l'
ai appris plus tard ce que c'était parce
que c'était pas mal rohff
nous sommes éternellement reconnaissants
pour tous ceux et celles qui ont
participé à cette bataille qui est à
jamais gravé dans la mémoire des
canadiens et des canadiennes
le 6 juin 1944 le jour j le jour de la
plus grande opération militaire combinée
de l'histoire d'une 6
[Musique]
pierre gauthier soldats finalement là
demain matin nous ont ils ont marché
vers le bas au fond là on à bakchich
d'igloo bateau c'est du bateau macha et
puis en italie dans la cale de ces
bateaux viola on ne va pas de place pour
ceux qui ne vendent rien à manger on se
demande à qui on n'a rien dit qu on sent
là bas quelque chose de pas mal sérieux
[Musique]
tous nous tourner ce
c'est un de mes yeux dieuze bédouins way
mongolie et nous
le scandale m
et pour
monsieur
[Musique]
non
c'est qui
laurent
dell
oh
les besoins
sous
on voit les uns
[Musique]
les flammes
e
m
oh
sacrifice
ce
à tous
zhu
[Musique]
tous
m
[Musique]
ces îlots
oh
boulin dieu d eux jean louis chanseau a
su agen 2
et
certains
[Musique]
m
zohra et
[Musique]
c'est à elle
non
[Applaudissements]
ces moments
ok
c
[Musique]
moment
tu
c'est mieux
[Musique]
oh
vaincus merci les nécessiteux originaire
de st john's terre neuve avec les
seniors hommes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je m'appelle jacqueline je travaille
dans une usine de munitions je n'ai
jamais dit à mon mari que je vais pas
qu'ils son rôle
je garde ma colère à l'intérieur de moi
qu'il n'a pas droit de risquer sa vie
pour libérer un pays où il n'a jamais
mis les pieds
comment dire à un homme qui n'a pas
droit de partir sans savoir s'il
reviendra qui n'a pas droit de quitter
sa famille ses amis et moi me font
rigoler je suis enceinte
chaque jour je prie pour que mon enfant
et la chance de connaître et son père
autour de moi beaucoup de femmes vivent
la même angoisse
mes parents et moi sommes réunis autour
la radio on annonce le débarquement
je sais que tu es là je pense à toi je
pense à tous les amis mes voisins ni les
habitants mon quartier qui sont là avec
toi il ya plus beaucoup de hargne
ma mère pleure en silence tandis que mon
père fait les sympas et moi je me
souviens de notre mariage
la première fois que je t'ai vu en
uniforme ans le jour où tu m'as dit que
tu avais peur de ne pas être à la
hauteur
en l'espace d'un instant ma peur pendant
quoi ma colère se transforme en fierté
oneworld
[Musique]
chiasson et venir votre aventure come
back
[Applaudissements]
une jeune romaine mesdames et messieurs
nous sommes honorés d'avoir avec nous
aujourd'hui
le lieutenant général honoraire reacher
romane voici son témoignage qu'il est
histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en tant que de reconnaissance
on travaille ce n'était pas de tenter de
crever
danone cède 0,2
[Musique]
m
et r
non
[Musique]
poirier
saute à edgar doit rien
[Musique]
une fois débarqué sur la plage on est à
plat ventre on était à quatre pattes
pour se cacher les balle arrivait de
partout
il y avait des allemands dans l'église
qui était alors qu'ils tiraient sur nous
pour nous en empêcher d'arriver à terre
et l'eau les bateaux en arrière en tirer
sur l'église la mitrailleuse a arrêté
possède bouffe est allé partout sur la
plage y avait des mines la broche les
collants tuer il vient là qui se prenait
les pieds là dedans ça se lamentait il y
avait des jambes de partie il y en a qui
criait mama mais je me suis rendu
jusqu'à la côte on sert anti jusqu'à la
côte
plus
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs les résines le
très honorable justin trudeau premier
ministre du canada
[Musique]
on est sexe ne devaient pas perdre et
votre six points d'accès ce sont les
crucial pour le succès de l'opération ne
te jure j il s'est embarqué dans la
flotte
dassault s'est lancé l'assaut de la
plage nord s'approchant de relâche les
éléments de l'opération neptune fait ce
qu'ils avaient été entraînés par fin
von neumann cramer web non comme lui à
coup sûr la plage en direction de la
cheminée concerne le second belge et en
allemagne
normand kobe
comme normand courbit jean 30 venez
juste tout juste d'avoir 19 ans lors du
débarquement de normandie
originaire de montréal lui aussi était
loin de chez lui il s'est dirigé vers la
rive sous la pluie les bombardements
allemands
il se souviendra toute sa vie du carnage
dont il a été témoin ce jour là ni cris
de ses camarades blessés par les balles
et les bombes des corps sans vie qui
jonchaient la plage le corps des siens
le soldat de lieutenant et même de
capitaine tombé au combat
jean 30 affirmera plus tard qu'il a vu
le meilleur et le pire de l'être humain
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale
fantine 14 villes canadiennes sont
lancées 12 jours mais là c'était vous le
départ où les dd comme jamais le mot
[Musique]
division 13 ème division
en fait parmi ces gens parmi ses soldats
les premières nations sont devenus une
seule force militaire pour libérer le
territoire de nos alliés france et le
reste c'est ce que c'est con libérer les
opprimés précis de garde pour défendre
démocratie il trop de canadiens auront
réussi à avancer plus loin en terre
ennemie que n'importe quel autre armée
lors du débarquement de normandie nous
soldats venaient d'entrer dans
l'histoire
mais ce soir là ils pleureront la perte
dessus qu'ils ne reverront jamais notre
pays la perte de paires de frères et de
fils qui il y à 75 ans jour pour jour
ont fait le sacrifice de leur vie pour
leurs concitoyens pour les générations
futures pour vous et moi plus de 5000
canadiens sont tombés sur les champs de
bataille de la normandie 75 ans plus
tard nous nous souvenons de l'ampleur de
leur sacrifice nous souvenons notamment
des compagnies
la première vague et les queens of
canada qui ont subi des pertes énormes
dans les premières heures du jour j
nous rappelons leur courage leur
ténacité et leur générosité
we take terme d'un long et fraudeurs
sacre face par exemple
les remercions pour pour nous avoir
légué le meilleur que ce que celui dans
lequel ils ont fait du nil heures devant
une énorme dette de grâce et de
gratitude à tous ces hommes qui ont
combattu sur les plages de normandie et
dans la tête des valeurs de paix et de
démocratie définissent notre pays
mais l'héritage qu'ils nous ont légué
s'étend bien au delà de nos frontières
ils ont façonné le monde dans lequel
nous vivons
ils ont tissé les liens d'amitié sur
lesquels repose une relation avec tant
de pays aujourd'hui ils ont expiré les
grands forums internationaux qui
régissent l'univers diplomatique et
forums comme l'onu l'otan la banque
mondiale et j'en passe grâce à grâce aux
sacrifices qu'ils ont su faire il ya
maintenant 75 ans notre monde est plus
sûr plus connectés et plus pacifique
qu'il ne l'était à l'époque reste un
jean louis
je suis ici devant sacha que je ne
pourrai jamais vraiment comprendre ce
que nos braves soldats l'uniforme en ont
vécu c'est seulement ceux qui se sont
lancés contre la forêt sur un pan
normandie seul lui connaît ce qui s'est
passé ici
il a 75 ans mais si la responsabilité de
tous les canadiens de s'assurer que leur
histoire et leur sacrifice
ne soient jamais oubliées il ne dépend
que de nous départ de nous de préserver
cet héritage et de soutenir cet héritage
et nous ne laisserons pas tomber
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
veuillez accueillir un incontournable de
la chanson québécoise
l'auteur compositeur interprète luc de
la chenelière signé luc de la chenelière
où était ce en beauté perdue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sûr j'en aurai du courage
j'en ai souvent avant
je sors des faits très marage
et laisserait filer le temps
[Musique]
et j'irai poser des armes
l avant d'ouvrir le feu
mais il en faudra bien plus
face à la montée
[Musique]
je n'aurais jamais à ces dames
je n'ai jamais
vos biens
ce je vais continuer ma vie
je partirai d'autres maisons
et jérémy jour minuit
habiter d'autres visions
j'aurais même si c'est la femme
une vie qui ferait des envieux
[Musique]
perdu
je n'aurais jamais cela
[Musique]
déjà mais sega
eh bien non
et la vie sûrement
ton visage qui m'accuse
chaque jour et jusqu'au cercueil
[Musique]
une crue et demi
et qui fait vente
la salle
et du désespoir
le chant du poids
sûr il y aura d'autres murs et toits les
couchers de soleil
les joies deviendront les quais
la terre va tourner pareil
j'vais même surfer sur des drames
sous le
musée du dos
[Musique]
ce tabou
je n'aurais jamais à ces dames
pour bien on avait les yeux
tori jamais assez car
pour bien manger
et les yeux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous animons
[Musique]
on n'était pas un hôpital où la 23e
ambulance en étant un poste de secours
avancé il pouvait mettre 3 civière
partie nous autres on les prenait on les
emmenait à la tente où le médecin et
changer les pansements pu regarder ce
qui pouvait être fait
après ça de chez nous on les renvoyer en
arial
oui tout
yobi technique
janot coulibaly
c'est
[Musique]
nous sommes en dessous
m
faux
[Musique]
m
ça ne semble pas blessé il n'avait
émergé ce n'est pas sa magie porteuse
agnostique
ils devaient les plus grands yeux bleus
j'ai jamais vu un beau garçon et il a
dit de la manière la plus polie qui soit
presque oublié ma mère et lui dire que
j'étais blessé et j'ai dit oui
aussitôt que je reviendrai et je vous
dis que là je suis revenue et tout ce
que j'ai vu c'était une couverture grise
j'ai presque perdu connaissance
alphonse vautours mesdames et messieurs
veuillez vous joindre à nous pour l'acte
du souvenir qui sera récitée par les
vétérans canadiens jim parks alphonse
vautours et esmerine veuillez répondre
par nous nous souviendrons d'eux
les jeunes accros
[Musique]
il vieillit on part comme nous qui leur
avons survécu
ils ne connaîtront jamais litrage ni le
poids des années
quand viendra l'heure du crépuscule et
celle de laura
nous nous souviendrons d'eux
[Applaudissements]
shopping et ayant expiré le moral quand
elle est hot et à mort
tintin lucky bâtiment autant que trois
cépages autochtones
[Musique]
en
nationale de france le ministère de la
défense nationale a le regret de vous
annoncer de trop nombreuses familles oui
le malheur de recevoir ce télégramme
dévastateur
[Musique]
convaincu qu'il allait revenir de la
guerre giorgio s make a écrit à ses
parents pour leur dire de ne pas
s'inquiéter
il est mort le 7 juin 1944 et peu après
ses frères ont subi le même sort
[Musique]
ça
non
[Musique]
les matins
oui
les lanteigne de caraquet au
nouveau-brunswick n'ont jamais revu
partir jean baptiste et philippe
vouloir des pauvres de nous ils sont
morts pour notre liberté
leurs noms vie pour les générations
[Musique]
fait notre part qui n'entrent pas avare
et l'extraordinaire je pourrais dire
mais moi j'étais dans un détachement
d'artillerie
ces détachements là qui a reçu 1 1 n'est
pas direct les douze les gens qui
étaient autour de la pièce format tout
ce qu'on entend c'est rob redoutait la
passat a serré mais c'est ça sucré
[Applaudissements]
c'est un privilège de les avoir parmi
nous aujourd'hui
voici le groupe autochtone canadien
bigot
[Musique]
[Rires]
après
ouais
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jacques raymond l'abattage mal avec un
pic est proche prieto semaines avant
qu'on puisse conquérir you de long c'est
tellement d'amis qui fait état par
agacer les vieilles avait appuyé le
bouton avait pas
[Musique]
oui
ce que
oui oui
etc
oui
anja weemove donne
[Musique]
oui forte
il
[Musique]
maintenant mais que tout
car la famille
paris
[Musique]
marie
mesdames et messieurs les ng romaine
veille accueilli autre histoire comme
monsieur edouard philippe
monsieur edouard philippe premier
ministre de la république française
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs tous étaient volontaires
tous étaient volontaires et ce n'était
pas le cas des autres contingents
nationaux qui débarquèrent le 6 juin
mais les canadiens l'était volontaires
pour partir à l'autre bout du monde pour
défendre la liberté l'état de droit la
démocratie au péril de leur vie
malgré le raid de dieppe et ses 900
morts le 19 août 1942 leur détermination
n'avait pas faibli pendant les mois
d'entraînement qui précédèrent le dis
dès les vétérans s'attendait au pire
mais il raconte qu'il voulait y aller
qu'ils étaient impatients
ceux qui ont survécu décrivent un enfer
qui dépassent leur imagination
sous les ordres du général keller la
troisième division canadienne débarque
sur la plage de juno beach dans des
conditions éprouvantes à marée haute
ce qui la rend plus vulnérable aux
obstacles disposés par e mail malgré de
lourdes pertes ces héros ouvre une
première brèche vers la liberté
la france restera toujours redevable aux
soldats canadiens qui ont participé au
débarquement et à la bataille de
normandie
elle sera toujours redevable aux hommes
et aux femmes de la marine marchande du
canada de la marine royale du canada et
de l'aviation royale du canada
ils se sont illustrés sur tous les
théâtres d'opération et sur tous les
continents
l'effort de guerre canadien a contribué
à faire du canada une grande nation et
il a joué un rôle décisif pour la
libération de la france et de l'europe
nous serons toujours redevable hagard
tweb lieutenant de la 14e artillerie
puis fondateur du sandre john au beach
aller aux majors
ce guerrier exceptionnelle qui après
s'être illustré devait encore ce
n'aurait encore et nous serons toujours
redevable à gilbert boulanger
ce lieutenant d'aviation qui donnent
aujourd'hui son nom à une école de
courseulles sur mer et à tous ceux que
je ne pourrais pas nommé mais dont
certains sont présents ici parmi nous
aujourd'hui 75 ans après le jour j juno
beach n'est pas seulement le nom d'une
des cinq plages du débarquement et d'un
remarquable musée qui contribuent au
devoir de mémoire et de réflexion
historique
c'est l'un des noms de notre amitié
franco canadienne qui s' est aussi forgé
comme toute amitié dans les épreuves
nous célébrons cette année les 90 ans
des relations diplomatiques entre nos
deux pays mais nos deux nations nos deux
peuples se connaissent et partagent une
vie commune depuis bien plus longtemps
dans un monde qui s'affolent qui
accélère ses relations
leur intensité leur ancienneté sont
précieuses aujourd'hui les armées de nos
deux pays sont engagés côte à côte en
irak dans le cadre de la coalition
internationale qui luttent contre des ch
mais nous payons aussi d'autres combats
à mener ensemble l'urgence écologique
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
la diversité culturelle sont autant de
grands défis de civilisation que nous ne
pouvons pas relever seuls ces défis nous
allons les relever ensemble car nous
partageons une histoire et surtout des
valeurs nous allons les relevés grâce à
la qualité des liens qui unissent les
dirigeants de nos deux pays depuis un an
le premier ministre du canada nous a
honoré deux fois d'une visite en france
et le président de la république
française s'est rendue au canada en juin
et dans quelques jours le canada passera
le relais de la présidence du g7 à la
france et nous allons les relevés car
nous sommes nous aussi volontaire notre
jeunesse est volontaire comme les
combattants canadiens qui débarquèrent
le 6 juin 1944
et cette détermination reste la première
condition pour infléchir le cours de
l'histoire
beaucoup ici ont dit qu'ils ne pouvaient
pas imaginer la peur et le courage qu'il
avait fallu à ses hommes pour sortir des
bateaux et affronter cette plage pour
ceux qui viennent après il est difficile
de dire autre chose que mercy mais ce
merci est immense
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parce que jenny une journée très
excitante
toute une expérience de regarder
bombardier lancaster et de compter les
bombes dans la soute
les allemands tentaient de s'échapper de
la poche pour les airs et entouré de
plusieurs lignes de défense je sais pas
combien on a prise de prisonniers bien
là dans la faille de falaise bon après
je te plaise mais c'était dans les
centaines de milliers sans aucun doute
[Musique]
comme l'ont déjà écrit deux historiens
ils n'étaient pas tous des saints et des
héros mais il y avait des saints et des
héros parmi eux
[Musique]
eq cream cheese rose
les faits d'armes de léo majeur lui ont
valu de nombreuses distinctions dont
deux destinés aux chômeurs
parce que seulement
[Musique]
ce que seulement trois soldats ont
réussi à faire trois soldats du
commonwealth ont réussi à faire en deux
guerres différentes
léo major était un homme exceptionnel
un homme sans peur
un véritable héros
ils sont prêts à voir débarquer les aux
majors et d'autres soldats ont réussi à
détruire un nid mitrailleuse et à faire
douze prisonniers ennemis peu après il a
aussi réussi à capturer un véhicule
ennemi qui contenaient des livres codes
et des transmetteurs le feeling sur
dives
le sergent-major réussit aussi à
éliminer une patrouille allemande mais
il perd un oeil dans la bataille quand
on lui dit que sa guerre est finie il
refuse de quitter pour l'angleterre
après la bataille de normandie
léo majeur s'est distingué aux pays-bas
entre autres en libérant à lui seul une
ville entière
il a également pris part à la guerre de
corée
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs le major général
guy châtelaine aumônier général des
forces armées canadiennes animera la
prière
[Musique]
il faut une réflexion gode wind at work
in his three two days in de présence aux
forces canadiennes v trance de levin
mbour 10 min
aux valeurs en service oui parce que
remember au men and women who surf au
country soda twinlight lives in freedom
and peace en ce 75e anniversaire du
débarquement du jour j nous nous
souvenons des plus de 14 mille membres
de la marine royale canadienne de
l'armée canadienne et de l'aviation
royale canadienne qui ont participé à
cette bataille acharnée de juno beach
nous nous souvenons du 6 juin 1944 comme
l'un des moments décisifs de la seconde
guerre mondiale un jour gravé dans notre
mémoire nous nous souvenons du prix que
l'humanité doit parfois payer pour
parvenir à la paix andy des eaux
canadiennes for those who are not alone
on dit homefront des world supported by
jove entre en france
un badaud des supporteurs
each other
de corey jane determination of
canadiennes ont dit des was not willing
finale canadienne
on m'a dit tu m'aides sacrifice honda d
ennery member solesmes duty to own eyes
le torch d'has been personne douce
nous nous souvenons du peuple français
pour qui la guerre à frapper à leur
porte et transformer leurs paysages à
tout jamais nous rendons grâce pour les
hommes et les femmes en uniforme
aujourd'hui engagé à défendre nos droits
et nos libertés ainsi que nos
institutions démocratiques paix s'il ne
jamais oublier les leçons tirées des
champs de bataille et de l'horreur de la
guerre oui gardois firmware one another
world est terminée sean tories moved by
heart of john and spirit of
réconciliation oui prix to you for the
leader of the world en forte hausse au
folk country for the lady de queen of
canada photo members of royal familles
et nos services to be love canada and
commonwealth winch wu guanzhong de prime
minister and chief of de défense staff
finally we pray for all the people of
canada fall to do zoom et des sacrifices
halloween gosse to enjoy the blessing au
freedom and peace
mais dès ce vaisseau ennemi ans oui on
strive to continue the first to build a
bear the world amen
[Musique]
la promesse de se souvenir sera récitée
par jay snap et comores johnston
veuillez répondre avec nous nous
souviendrons d'eux un jeune comme nous
ils ont servi
donnant généreusement bout d'eux mêmes
me promettant en dépit du temps qui
passe de porter le flambeau et de ne
jamais oublier
nous nous souviendrons de leblanc
mesdames et messieurs veuillez vous
lever
alors que le caporal la dernière
sonnerie suivi d'une minute de silence
marqué par des coups de canon et le
réveil l'élégie suivra est apprêté par
le sergent chris leblanc
ah ah
à
oh
[Musique]
m
ma
oui
ah ah
ou pas
à
m
pas
pareil
[Musique]
m
et
baa
ouais
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'avion que vous voyez arriver est un
avion de transport hercules c130j
[Musique]
ok
on se 1000 avions 14 1674 sortie presque
cent cinquante cinq mille trous d'allier
donc quatorze mille canadiens
ces chiffres nous raconte qu'une partie
de l'histoire
[Musique]
quand
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
n'oublions jamais les sacrifices de ses
vétérans qui sont ici avec nous
aujourd'hui et surtout de ceux qui n'y
sont pas
mesdames et messieurs nous distinguer
invité les premiers ministres du canada
et de la république française déposeront
les gerbes d'honneur le dépôt des gerbes
sera accompagné par la musique des
forces armées canadiennes et le corps de
cornemuses et de tambours qui joueront
depuis la plage
et maintenant nous invitons le premier
ministre du canada le très honorable
justin trudeau et monsieur edouard si
les premiers milices de la république
française a déposé les gerbes
auj
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà mesdames et messieurs cette
cérémonie en hommage aux soldats
canadiens se termine elle s'achève
maintenant voler les premiers ministres
qui déposent des gerbes sur cette plage
mythique vraiment donc une cérémonie à
travers laquelle on a revécu un peu tous
les événements la préparation du
débarquement le débarquement lui même et
la suite les batailles qui ont suivi
avec des acteurs on a revécu un peu tout
seul ces paradis oui avec nos toits
jacquin au toit jeune narrateur ils ont
ont fait bien sentir ce que chaque
soldat vivaient ont vécu lors de cette
journée du 6 juin 1944
comment est ce qu'ils voyaient leurs
camarades tombés autour d'auch 2 et
comment ils devaient parvenir à franchir
cette plage et ça se diriger vers le
village de leurs objectifs
alors on s'est vraiment sensibles comme
ceux qui débarquait sur la plage et
c'est un hommage en fait à ses vétérans
qu'on voyait dans l'eau sur le dans la
première rangée qui ont vécu ça alors si
le lien entre cette cérémonie est ce
qu'ils ont vécu et les familles aussi
parce qu'il n'y avait on
on a eu on a vu les femmes de soldats
qui sont exprimés on a vu des
infirmières aussi bref on a revécu toute
cette période
il ya aussi eu cette allocation du
premier ministre si edouard philippe qui
a aussi rendu hommage être au travail
des soldats canadiens est ce qu'ils ont
fait aux liens aussi qui miss la france
et le canada
et c'est important parce qu'on voyait
tous ces normands qui sont réunis là au
centre juno et je me disais en fait il
ya eu beaucoup de pertes civiles du côté
des normands oui tous ces bombardements
ramenant le débarquement
mais il ya quand même la gratitude qui
l'avait payé soldats canadiens sont
venus libéré
ben oui on peut facilement dire que les
normands ont payé le lourd prix de leur
libération par la destruction la
normandie s'est reconstruite pendant
plusieurs décennies jusqu'aux années 60
même pour une bataille qui aura duré
quelques semaines finalement et puis oui
le discours de philippe marc vraiment
des points très importants ils se
tournent vers le futur les relations
franco canadienne la normandie devient
une toile de fond pour émettre les
désirs pour le futur je pense qu'ils
s'adressent aussi à une façon de
respecter les vétérans de leur parler de
nos objectifs du futur ensemble ils
parlent d'écologie parle de diversité de
d'égalité c'est quand même des énoncés
qui ont un impact et ses toiles dans le
contexte politique actuel ce sont des
mots importants
oui alors de parmi eux il y aurait une
cérémonie un peu plus tard une cérémonie
internationale on note quand même des
absences l'absence peut-être de la
russie qui n'est pas présente à ces
cérémonies là depuis quelques jours et
pour le reste de la journée la russie
qu'elle quand même joué un rôle très
important parce que ce débarquement
cette bataille de normandie c'est une
étape dans la guerre le le front le
front s était vraiment extrêmement aigu
d'union soviétique dû subir la la chaux
de la marche de l'armée allemande en 41
et ce combat fut titanesques entre les
forces soviétiques et l'armée allemande
en fait la majorité des forces
allemandes ont toujours été concentré de
1941 à 1945 sur le front est
alors que le front est neuf ans plus tôt
pour hitler et un front secondaire dont
il fallait en terme de nombre en termes
d'eau de mer etc
- oui alors légèrement perdu en fait
neuf soldats sur le front est ce qu'on
bâtiment g n'empêche que ça ouvre la
voie relais divers la libération de la
france et éventuellement vers la défaite
de l'allemagne nazie comme la victoire
qui viendra seulement plus tard le 8 mai
45 avec de nombreuses pertes canadiennes
évidemment on a joué un rôle
probablement encore une fois
disproportionné par rapport à notre
démographie à l'époque les canadiens se
sont démarqués ont souvent eu des
batailles moins glorieuse que celle des
américains des britanniques
mais c'est vrai qu'on se trouvaient
présents dans la
bataille assez importantes qui sont
moins connus entre la soul nie la
bataille de carpiquet pour l'aérodrome
de caen on a souligné aussi celle de
falaise
bataille important voyez on a dit on
disait que les canadiens se sont avancés
on avance et on fait le plus d'avancé
par rapport aux autres armées comme un i
may a fallu rattraper après je ne fallut
que les troupes les plus aventureux
recul parce que les troupes britanniques
n'étaient pas à la même hauteur il y
avait un risque à ce moment là que des
événements prennent entonna il est
rempli plus avancé effectivement dans
les jours suivants pour atteindre les
objectifs qui avaient été prévus pour la
première journée
ça me prive plusieurs jours même voir
plusieurs chemins mènent à capturer
l'aéroport de carpiquet la ville de caen
les pertes furent du sévère que
certaines journées en fait les pertes
furent plus sévères qu'aujourd'hui et
canadiens perdure pendant les sept ou
huit semaines de la campagne de
normandie
environ 5000 tuées et treize mille
blessés
alors c'était un sacrifice énorme pour
quelques semaines de bataille faut
partir quand même de s'en rappeler un de
tout ça c'est le devoir de mémoire est
important
ça va au delà d'un devoir je pense
qu'ils nous on se concentre sur une
journée dans l'année comme ça un moment
fort mais le travail de mémoire la
transmission de la mémoire de travail de
dialogue intergénérationnel c'est ça qui
va faire en sorte que malgré l'absence
des vétérans dans les années qui vont
venir on va être capable de continuer de
prendre la mesure de l'ampleur de ce qui
a été réalisé par ces gens là une fois
qu'ils nous ont quittés je pense que les
vétérans souhaite d'abord et avant tout
que nous on arrive à souvenirs sans leur
leur z parce que ils savent qu'ils vont
partir donc on a une certaine forme de
surdépendance sur nos vétérans
actuellement et il faut trouver des
moyens de transmettre avec autant de
pertinence avec autant d'impact dans le
futur c'est ça le défi maintenant qu'ils
auquel on doit faire face
oui ce que c'est ce que vous faites
d'ailleurs au centre de
une wii en six affaires depuis 15 ans
puis on a l'intention de rester sur
place et continuer l'effort doit être
fait dans nos écoles aussi apprendre à
nos jeunes de prendre la relève de ce
devoir de mémoire la prendre la relève
de ses vétérans qui disparaissent les
uns après les autres maintenant mais qui
étaient là tout fier d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui
alors on va on va aller retourner à
courseulles-sur-mer retrouver jean
françois bélanger donc jean-françois
vous étiez vous sur place david eu le
vivre un peu différemment de nous
quittions loin et c'était quand même
émouvant très émouvant surtout pour tous
ces étudiants qui ont fait le voyage
sont venus des quatre coins du canada
pour être ici présent beaucoup d'autres
heures en fait on de la famille parmi
les militaires ils ont entendu parler de
ces batailles là et ce discours sur
l'importance de mémoire est important de
se souvenir et ben ils y sont bien
évidemment très très sensible et puis
ils ont été applaudis les anciens
combattants eux aussi ému tout comme le
premier
justin trudeau quand il ya évoqué ces
gens dont qui ont risqué leur vie donc
pour libérer l'europe donc on a senti
très aigu justin trudeau lorsqu'il a dit
donc que c'est grâce à eux que l'on peut
maintenant vivre en paix et en liberté
des mots aussi qui a lancé
son homologue français edouard philippe
qui a dit à quel point la france était
redevable du sacrifice de ces jeunes
canadiens donc qui ont tout quitté
parcouru des milliers de kilomètres
convenir
jusqu'ici le seul mot qui convient dans
ces circonstances a dit edouard philippe
c'est merci alors que donc les
cérémonies se poursuit on en est
vraiment sur la fin un moment clé de
cette cérémonie alors que les anciens
combattants qui sont ici présents se
dirige vers la plage pour les porter des
gerbes de fleurs comme l'ont fait avant
eux donc peu près ministre justin
trudeau et son homologue français
edouard philippe
beaucoup des mines d'émotion bien
évidemment alors que ses anciens
combattants la retourne sur la plage
qu'ils ont foulé 75 ans plutôt bien
évidemment dans des conditions très
différentes fallait imaginer donc c'est
pas difficile sous le feu ennemi ya 75
ans aujourd'hui s'est laissée sous les
applaudissements des français qu'ils
font c'est pas une autre cérémonie un
peu plus tard au même endroit une
cérémonie internationale jean-françois
tout à fait donc une cérémonie qui sera
cette fois présidé par edouard philippe
vous savez cet achat qu à chaque
occasion comme ça la cérémonie
internationale se déplacent d'endroit en
endroit cette année il a été décidé que
ce serait le juno beach le secteur
canadien qui recevrait l'honneur de
cette cérémonie internationale on
entendra encore une fois donc le premier
ministre justin trudeau et puis le prg
ministre edouard philippe
justin trudeau qui doit rencontrer sur
le président français demain matin à
l'elysée donc près donc
d'après cette journée là justin trudeau
prendre la route direction paris pour
rencontrer d'entreprises en france est
très bien alors
une émission spéciale sera présentée
donc ça sera présenté à à 12h37
cérémonie internationale merci jean
françois et il n'y a pas qu'en france où
on souligne ce 75e anniversaire du
débarquement le fera aussi ici au canada
entre autres à ottawa et halifax où on
rejoint famille bussières mcnicoll fanny
donc cette cérémonie halifax cet après
midi elle a dû être déplacé à
l'intérieur en raison de la pluie
voilà céline cette cérémonie elle doit
débuter à 13h30 heure de l'est
mais malheureusement allait être dur
elle a dû être déplacée elle devait se
dérouler du côté du lieu historique de
la citadelle d'halifax mais en raison
des conditions météorologiques très
difficiles aujourd'hui on attend plus de
60 mm de pluie halifax et vient on a
décidé de le déplacer du côté des lieux
un peu plus couvert un peu moins
historiquement ou symboliquement
intéressant mais quand même plus
couverts c'est à dire le monument le
manège militaire de willow pays qui se
trouve derrière moi donc malgré tout la
cérémonie va débuter par une salve de 21
coups de canon qui saura tirer pour
accueillir le début de la cérémonie et
les invités d'honneur parmi ses invités
de marque céline il y aura notamment la
gouverneure générale du canada julie
payette ainsi que sept vétérans
canadiens qui ont participé au
débarquement de normandie en 1944
on attend également plusieurs
dignitaires et il y aura au total plus
de 400 personnes des dignitaires des
militaires sont attendus à cette
cérémonie céline elle sera célébrée au
elle sera célébrée en l'honneur des
quatorze mille soldats canadiens qui ont
participé au débarquement de normandie
il s'agit aujourd'hui de la troisième
journée de commémoration qui se trouve
du côté d'halifax
parce que la ville d'halifax et le port
d'halifax représente un endroit
particulièrement symbolique très très
intéressant et très important au niveau
du débarquement en normandie parce que
c'est ici que la majorité des soldats
canadiens sont partis à partir pour
partir de normandie sont partis à partir
du port d'halifax
très bien merci beaucoup aux fans y est
il y aura aussi une cérémonie
commémorative donc à 11h à ottawa alors
voilà c'est déjà tout pour nous
une toujours un moment émouvant ce genre
de cérémonies qui nous rappelle tout ce
qui s'est passé et les sacrifices qu'ont
fait ces anciens combattants pour la
souligner pour qu'on puisse vivre comme
on fait aujourd'hui
oui absolument c'est je pense que
commémorer c'est absolument pas
glorifier et c'est ce qu'ils ont réussi
et la guerre non il ya une distinction
et je pense qu'on le voit dans les
entrevues vous avez fait avec gauthier
trempe on l'entend dans les témoignages
des acteurs on cherche à ne pas
glorifier mais a commémoré cet important
de distinguer les les deux choses il
fallait passer par cette journée par
cette guerre pour amener la liberté la
paix et le combat pour la démocratie
rétablir la démocratie en europe leur
offre ça aurait été bien différent sur
l'opération n'avait pas réussi oui
beaucoup différents merci beaucoup à
vous deux d'avoir été avec nous merci
alors voilà mesdames messieurs qui
conclut cette émission spéciale 75 ans
après le jour le plus long cette journée
de reconnaissance envers ceux qui se
sont battus pour la liberté n'est pas
fini dont vous pourrez revoir les
meilleurs moments de cette cérémonie à
au réseau de l'information à 20 heures
et à 22 heures
merci d'avoir été là nous retournons à
notre programmation régulière
[Musique]
ban